the un's refugee agency is warning that
afghanistan needs urgent support from
the international community to prevent a
larger humanitarian crisis the comments
come as some countries suggest they will
only engage with the taliban if they
agree to respect human rights in
particular those of women and girls
we'll have more from our correspondent
in kabul on developments on the ground
in a moment but first this report
the buzz of kabul streets has slowly
been returning in the past month
it appears there's peace in the afghan
capital
which some residents have welcomed
but despite the improvement in the
security situation
certain sections of society fear and
reject the heavily armed taliban
there have been protests by women who
are angry at their new undefined role in
society
they fear misogynistic violence and
their rights being curtailed
their presence on the streets of towns
and cities across afghanistan has been
significantly altered
the taliban have said they can get an
education but men and women have already
been segregated at schools and
universities
in the media too journalists have spoken
of being on the receiving end of
intimidation and violence for carrying
out their work
thousands of afghans have already left
their homeland in recent weeks and it's
expected many more will do so in the
future
the exodus or plans to leave are not
only driven out of fear but also because
of afghanistan's dire economic situation
the taliban need billions of euros in
aid and investment from the
international community if they're to
help improve the lives of ordinary
people and prevent a humanitarian
catastrophe
but afghanistan's interim government
faces an uphill battle to convince
skeptical governments it won't rule in
the same authoritarian style it did from
1996 to 2001.
with rumors of a split in leadership it
may not just be on the international
stage that the taliban faces challenges
can it remain united and avoid further
political turmoil in an already weary
afghanistan
for more on the situation in afghanistan
let's cross over to journalist ali
latifi in kabul ali there have been
reports of a split in the taliban
leadership what's your impression
the split has existed basically since
2015 when the death of omar was
announced and if you look at what
happened
in the wake of that you know the haqqani
network was brought into the taliban
they were given that high level deputy
position
was also given a high level position
because again there was this um
big controversy and outcry over
uh the the chain of command and over who
would inherit the leadership of the
taliban um so this has been going on for
a long time now and we're seeing that
same issue rise up now wherein you're
seeing loyalists to the haqqani network
and loyalists for the taliban leadership
who are mostly in doha including
who is the head of their political
office you know we're seeing them
clash with each other and you see that
in the way they conduct themselves on
the street you can tell
who is alive with the hotline who is
alive with the other talents um and this
is this is really the issue that's been
going on uh
since they came to power because you
know as much as
they
wanted to
rightfully talk about all of the discord
in the former government now they're
realizing that once you get to the
presidential policies you will likely
find yourself in a very similar
situation
well the economic crisis there is
worsening of banks running out of cash
food prices soaring at the authorities
unable to pay salaries how is that
affecting the taliban's rule
uh
it doesn't necessarily well i mean it
does affect the taliban's rule because
people
you know are upset that in these you
know last three weeks they haven't been
able to gain access to money and things
like that but we have to remember that
this is a result of policy by the imf
the world bank the u.s federal reserve
this was money that was either that
either belonged to the afghan government
or with promised
government that they cut off as soon as
the taliban took over even though
all of these countries knew that the
taliban was taking over germany has been
talking to the taliban since 2011.
norway has been the united states has
been the united states signed an
agreement with them in 2020.
they all live in country i mean germany
was one of the last countries to leave
they were here to see the taliban take
over
and then all of a sudden when it happens
they cut off the funding and what
happens is not the taliban that suffer
it's the average person
ali latifah there in kabul for us many
thanks ali